ist die deutsche justiz am limit wir
schalten wir live an das landgericht
köln so richter matthias matschke warum
fanden sie dann noch zu so später stunde
weil es mir unglaublich spaß macht er
wecke ich kann mir einfach nichts
schöneres vorstellen als hier bis in die
puppen zu arbeiten und vor der rente nie
mehr nach hause zu kommen
das war sarkasmus ach so wissen sie
eigentlich was hier los ist uns fehlen
bundesweit mindestens 2000 richter und
staatsanwälte
zum glück beherrsche ich multitasking
ich unterschreibe zb mit der rechten
hand urteile yahoo und gleichzeitig
mache ich links ein käsefondue mit
meiner frau weil wir sonst gar kein
privatleben mehr haben
das ist jetzt keine wirklich schlecht
ich muss hier haase tut mir leid 06 kann
ich mir bis weihnachten auch abschnitten
mein aufrichtiges bedauern zumal die
ganzen asylverfahren kommen bei ihm ja
noch und ob ganz genau zwei von drei
abgelehnten asylbewerbern klagen gegen
ihre abschiebung da steht ja alles auch
warum es geht einfach nicht mehr aber
gut für die asyl sache hatte ich jetzt
nicht ganz pfiffige idee ich zeigt
einfach meinem hund ein foto vom
asylbewerber und dann entscheidet der
das mit der abschiebung pech gehabt ja
man muss als wie ich da auch mal
delegieren können sagen sie mal aber so
kann es ja nicht weitergehen allein beim
berliner sozialgericht stapeln sich
gerade habe ich gewesen
40.000 unbearbeitete fälle die bude da
müsste ein jahr dicht machen um alle
verfahren abzuarbeiten
völlig richtig genau deswegen führe ich
jetzt immer zwei prozesse gleichzeitig
so damit ich nicht durcheinanderkommen
sie in dem hässlichen jogginganzug
sie waren der kriminelle banker der 300
milliarden versenkt nein ich bin der
tankwart mit den drei geklauten sanifair
bons
das ist das hinterletzte sanifair bons
clown der betreiber der tankstelle an
ihnen vertraut verstehe dann sind sie
also herr finke und haben 300 milliarden
versenkt selbst wenn ich darf man
überhaupt nicht vor gericht stellen
ich bin banker dazu beweisstück a diese
goldene rolex
und die beweist was ja dass sich banker
wenn du arschloch
mein fehler bin sehr über arbeit
außerdem verklage ich die bundesrepublik
deutschland ich verlange eine
persönliche entschuldigung der kanzlerin
mit einer packung mordserie im übrigen
sind hier weitere 500 beweisanträge da
geht es in erster linie um meine heilig
sprechen 12.37 uhr zwischen frage kann
es sein dass sie das verfahren hier
künstlich in die länge ziehen wollen
das ist eine sehr gute frage euer hirn
die ich auch gleich beantworten werde
moment sekunden
ich bin raus so langsam verdaut schon
wieder verkehr
ich war jedes mal drauf rein tja herr
koslowski ich fürchte dann wird sich der
staat die 300 milliarden von ihnen holen
müssen was sarah in sanifair bons im
namen des volkes blablabla casinos
[Applaus]
chinas banken schuld